time for our scene and unseen segment
when we reveal the real stories behind
the headlines for that we turn to fox
news contributor raymond arroyo
raymond biden virtually toured an
electric vehicle plant
the other day right but there were some
short circuits along the way
i'll say and major conflicts of interest
laura which i'll get to in a moment
despite his vaccination the president
believe it or not
is still holed up in the white house and
the staff is clearly running the show
from the start this tour sounded like
visitation time at the rest home and
biden
stuck to the script we have you visiting
today
proterra a leading u.s manufacturer of
electric buses
batteries and charging infrastructure
proterra
sold its first electric bus in 2009
using funds from the recovery act
what sort of testing do you put the
buses through they tell me how does it
feel
how do you do the first plugin i mean
how's that how's that work
and what time is the sing-along nurse
betty
oh do you read everything written on
those cards
here's the problem with this virtual
tour of proterra
biden's energy secretary jennifer
granholm
owns at least five million dollars of
stock in this company laura
and she sat on the board of directors
for years
now this infrastructure bill that biden
and granholm are pushing
dedicates 174 million dollars
to the electric vehicle market and 45
billion to the zero emission buses that
the company builds
i mean the fix is in here this is a bad
luck
how do you how do you do that plug-in
deal
when you plug it in where do you plug it
is it like a toaster
or is the plug bigger do i get one of
those adapters
or whatever there was one concerning
moment during this proterra tour
for a tech company managing tech is
apparently a problem
thanks for the tour kid
[Laughter]
can't hear you kiddo
oh got her no here you go
take this
morgan maybe you can hold that phone a
little to speak a little closer to you
why don't you try it now
when bob is offering you tech advice
laura you're in trouble
so i worry about this federal subsidy
all right raymond george w bush
resurfaced and he's pushing a new book
of his paintings and of course bashing
the gop
if you were to describe the republican
party as you see it today
yeah how would you describe it uh i
would describe it as
isolationist protectionist and to a
certain extent nativist
thank you sir may i have another i
believe
there is a there's an obvious crisis at
the border
55 percent of americans in a quinnipiac
poll
have problems with the way joe biden is
handling it
what does president bush think he's
accomplishing by
by reverting he's appreciating himself
ingratiating himself he's saying this
for years
about the isms you know we got the
protectionism and and the xenophobiaism
and
whatever he used to say nativism but
former president bush's book
is a collection of his paintings of
immigrants
with a political purpose i do want to
say to congress
please put aside all the harsh rhetoric
about immigration i hope i can
help set a tone that is more respectful
about the immigrant one can create a lot
of fear
you know they're coming after you but
it's a nation that is willing to accept
the refugee
or the harm or the frightened uh to me
is a great nation
i i'm not sure of these and i'm not sure
if these amateur paintings laura well
intended though they be accomplished the
desired end i mean
look they're not exactly john singer
sergeants and if he wanted to
commemorate a marginalized group one
that mr bush
actually had a real impact upon he could
have captured iraqi christians say
brutalized by isis just a thought um
well he's an amateur painter there
raymond i couldn't
paint as well let's see but the good
news is he's taking painting lessons i
understand so
oh there's henry kissinger just did
someone tell him that's his painting
gosh god bless them well i'm waiting for
the finger paints
i'm waiting for the presidential finger
paints raymond he's but he hasn't
on the on the isms you forgot
isolationism
he accused us of that as well next time
the other
isms all right i should show you this
before
we get out uh kamala harris after the
chauvin announcement you need to just
see this we can't go to it raymond we're
going to have to hold it we have no time
raymond thank you